David Boder: [In English] München, September the 24th, 1946 at the UNRRA University in Deutsches Museum. The interviewee is now a young student, who simply calls himself Boguslaw. And like so many others he refuses...he refuses to, eh, give his full name, because he does not think it’s exactly very safe yet to talk.
David Boder: [In German] Also, Boguslaw, erzählen Sie mir etwas von dem polnischen Widerstand in, hm, in Polen.
Boguslaw [last name unknown]: Die polnische Wiederstandsbewegung hat seinen Anfang seit 1933. Ich hab zu der...also 1939 bin ich in die deutsche Widerstandsbewegung eingetreten.
David Boder: In die deutsche Widerstandsbewegung?
Boguslaw [last name unknown]: Nein, in die polnische Widerstandsbewegung eingetreten.
David Boder: Und zu wem sollte der Widerstand geleistet werden?
Boguslaw [last name unknown]: Der Widerstand...Widerstandsbewegung hatte seinen Zielkampf gegen die Deutschen.
David Boder: Hm.
Boguslaw [last name unknown]: [hustet] Wir haben...die, die deutsche Besatzung war besonders schwer in Polen und in manchen Gebieten musste sich die polnische Bevölkerung...musste eine...musste einen Ausweg finden, um sich zu verteidigen. Kann ich polnisch sprechen?
David Boder: Ja, reden Sie das Ganze in polnisch. Aber nicht zu schnell, aber...
Boguslaw [last name unknown]: [In Polish] Ja. Niemcy strasznie zapisalisie, w naszej...
David Boder: [In German] Aber in der Hauptsache reden Sie von sich selbst. Alles was Sie in der der Widerstandsbewegung getan haben.
Boguslaw [last name unknown]: Ja.
David Boder: Weiter.
Boguslaw [last name unknown]: [In Polish] Od roku tysiąc dzięcset trzydziestego-dziewiątego należałem do Polskiego Ruchu Opory. Niemcy po zajęciu terenów Polskich wszędzie wściskali się do nas...Wszędzie chcieli...zniszczyć wszystko co Polskie. Wywoźili do obozów koncentracyjnych. Ja sam w roku 1939 przeznaczony byłem do transportu do Dachau, Szczęsliwie udał mi sie biec i zaczełem pracować w Polskiej organizacji wojskowej. Cel organizacji była. Celem organizacji była walka z Niemcami, chodziło o zachowanie...Polskości. Chodziło oto ażeby nie wątpić wiarę zwycięstwa.
Boguslaw [last name unknown]: Od 1939 do 40 tego roku zaczeło się silne wszkolenie Polaków. Powstały szkoły wojskowe...szkoły podoficerskie...szkoły podchorążych które miały przygotować oficerów. Równocześnie z tym powstała prasa Polska podziemnia która od 1939 zaczeła funkcjonować. Powstało mase organizacji które potem łączą się i tworzą związek powstańcy.
Boguslaw [last name unknown]: Związek Powstańcy miał celu...przygotowanie społeczeństwa...do walki z Niemcami oraz...nie pozwolenie zwątpienie. Najpierw praca podręcała się do Zbierania bronie, do...wyszkoleniu wojskowym. Przechodzilo skolejno do sabotażu, Najpierw był tak zwany mały sabotaż chodziło. Potem mały sabotaż nawołujacy do sabotożanie Niemieckich zarządzeń, do...ackji przeciwko wywozowi Polaków do Niemiec, akcja która miała na celu uświadomienie Polaków co dzieje się w obozach Koncentracyjnych.
Boguslaw [last name unknown]: Następnie przyszła kolej na duży sabotaż. Sam pracowałem w likwidacji Gestapowców w [niezrozumiała część taśmy] likwidacji, przed Wielkim Piątkiem. Przed świętami Wielkanocy w 1943 wybuchło powstanie w getcie Żydowskim. Na trzy tygodnie przedtym dowóctwo nasze dowiedziało się Że getcie Żydowskim grozi, tak samie grozi likwidacja [niezrozumiałe] po zakończeniu walki w getcie organizacja Polska wydała pomocy do [niezrozumiałe] siedziałem w roku 1941 na Pawiaku. Widziałem straszne sceny, mordowania. Walenie żywcem na [niezrozumiałe] w piec. Następnie oficerowie Gestapo, a między innymi znany kat Warszawy Berger...[glos zanika zupełnie]
Boguslaw [last name unknown]: Następnie w więzieniu zrobiono mi kuracje głodową i solną. Dawano mi do każdej [słowo ginie] masę soli. Przytym nie dostawałem zupełnie wody, tak że cierpiałem okropnie z powodu pragnienia, Następnie po trzeciu mieśiącznym pobyciu w więzieniu zostałem ewakuowany obozu koncentralnego do Gross Rosen, To co się działo w więzieniu było tak straszne, tak makabryczne, rostrzelewano przytym setkami ludzi których co drugi co trzeci dzień wyciągano z więzienia...I rozstrzeliwano w grozach zburzonego getta, Na pięć dni przed Powstaniem wybuchu Warszawskim, wybuchło powstanie na Pawiaku [glos zanika]...gdy warunki były zbyt cięszkie i zostało ztłumione. Potem wszyscz. cały oddział trzeci na ktorym to powstanie wybuchło został rozstrzelany.
Boguslaw [last name unknown]: Przeżyłem w więzieniu...strasznie...ważyłem zdaje się czterdzieśći kilo, Kilogram, Traktownie bzło okropne. Bito, Wszędzie...na całym ciele masę znaków zostało po tym. Gdyby Niemcom dzisiaj powiedzić że oni cóś takiego robili nigdy nikt do tego się przyzna. Jednak na to są dowody i to widać, prawda, W obozie koncentracynym za naszym wstępie za powiedziano nam żebyśmy zapomnieli że jesteśmy ludzmi i jesteśmy tylko numerami. Bicie I katowanie było na każdym kroku. Ludzie mordowali jedni drugich. Więzien, więznia. Kapo to nie bzł człowiek, to był tak samo Ubermensch jak każdy gestapowiec, Jedno był kapo. Kapo przeważnie rekrutowali się...kapowie rekrutowali sie przeważnie z więżniów kriminalnych. Byli to przedstępco, notoryczni. Recedzwiści.
David Boder: Czy Niemcy. Polaki?
Boguslaw [last name unknown]: Większość była Niemców, zależy tylko w jakim obozie. Przeważnie byli Niemcy, byli pozatym sporo Rosjan. Byli starzy więżniowie, Polacy, Żydzi.
David Boder: Byli Żydzi kapo no Polskim Bloku?
Boguslaw [last name unknown]: Tak byli. Może Pan Profesor ma jakieś pytania?
David Boder: [Niezrozumiałe]
Boguslaw [last name unknown]: . . . po uwolniemiu przez Armje Anglo-Amerykańską przebywałem najpierw w obozie wojskowym, potem dowiedziałem się że są możliwości studiów. Przyjechałem do Monachium na studia. Studjuje obecnie muzikę [slowo ginie] Kończę drugi semstr.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes the report—very brief but very interesting report—of Mr. Boguslaw, a...[ends abruptly]